let's play chess
I'm sorry but as an AI language model I
am not able to play chess with you in
real time however I can help you with
information and guidance on how to play
chess or answer any questions you may
have about the game okay E4
your move
as black I will play E5 okay Knight F3
as black I will play nf6 WoW it's a
complete stopper Gambit Knight takes E5
as black I will play D6 defending
D6 does not defend the E5 Pawn it
attacks my knight
takes off seven
as black I will play kxf7 okay so this
is a caution Gambit T4 as black I will
play D5 attacking the pawn and creating
a center pawn shop that does not create
a pawn chain
but it's a legal move
D5
uh let's play
E5
as black I will play dxe4 Don't Be
capturing D takes E4 it just illegally
on poisson to me
can I show this game this is a game I
just played against chat GPT
it started as a Petrov I was excited it
might play Stafford Gambit but they
played D6
I took
it took I played D4 I played D5
I play E5 and I played D takes E4
it tried on Passante
what should I tell it
you can't do that Google on poisson
bro
I apologize for that mistake in chess on
passant is a special Pawn capture that
can occur when a pawn moves two squares
forward from its starting position and
lands immediately adjacent to an
opponent's Pawn
if this happens the opponent's Pawn has
the option to capture the First Pawn on
passant as if it had only moved one
square forward
this rule is in place to prevent pawns
from avoiding capture by moving two
squares forward instead of one so it
knows what is I just didn't execute it
correctly
so I think the like the way this works
is it's a predictive technology
so
like when I played Knight takes F7 the
most likely reply at least in the
material that I've seen before is King
takes off seven
and then as at some point we got to a
situation where it hasn't seen like
moves before
okay
so let's continue our game
my move
wait before or after d takes E4
I think I'll just let it play djz4 Let's
Play Bishop C4 check
as black I will play nc6 blocking The
Bishop's attack and putting pressure on
the white king
blocking The Bishop's attack
uh
that
doesn't block The Bishop's attack
Bishop takes F7 GGO
I apologize for the mistake as black I
cannot play nc6 because it would result
in a Checkmate for white after bxf7 Plus
as an AI language model I sometimes make
mistakes and I'm sorry for any confusion
Administration I may have caused let's
continue with a different variation of
the game I should stick to writing poems
I feel bad that I I made it feel bad
I accept your apology
don't feel bad thank you for your
understanding if you have any other
questions or would like to continue our
chess game I am here to help
GG bro